pro football talk live here at the
league meetings in arizona and right out
of the gates one of our good friends
corporate cousin our brother in arms
with nbcsportsboston.com
synergy out the wazoo he is a very
casual tom kern you got the right idea
with shorts man because let me tell you
it's a little warm here you're over here
in your wranglers i'm not sure it's
exactly what we were looking at hey man
brett favre's the pitch man for
wranglers or at least he was that's when
i bought my wranglers what am i supposed
to do this guy he's in the desert with
wranglers and work boots on i don't want
to get i don't want to get bit by a
rattlesnake right fair enough
so enough uh it's great to see it as
always uh second time in in less than a
week that we've spent time together i
don't know that i can handle any more
than that but on on more far more
serious subjects uh robert kraft one of
the patriots won't will be here at the
league meetings won't be speaking issued
a statement on saturday to kind of
address what he believed needed to be
addressed what was your reaction to the
statement that was issued he was trying
to thread the needle between apologizing
while not
claiming any responsibility that would
impact the case as he still tries to
wriggle out of not just the charge but
also having that video release so he's
in a fine spot do you think the video
will be released
at some point
yes okay and part of me thinks he should
do a jeff bezos move and say i don't
care here it is take a look you all want
to see it go ahead but that's
for another conversation i think on the
reaction to it from my end i understand
why he was anxious to have his voice out
there and i don't blame him for that
he's been a very out front an outspoken
owner over the course of time he's
developed a relationship with the region
and with so many different aspects of
the region in terms of philanthropy that
you have to say to people look
i'm not blind to this i'm not just out
here trying to fight this in court i
understand that the optics and the
things
that this reflects upon me aren't good
but on the other hand too i think that
he has to try and maintain a level of
i don't know if it's
non-culpability
yeah he's asking us to suspend disbelief
right this was not an illegal act as a
former lawyer i see what he said and i
look at that and i say why even issue
anything why acknowledge responsibility
why apologize for anything because if
this does go forward if there is at some
point a trial they can use anything that
you say against you even if you don't
testify they can just issue the
statement what's he apologizing for you
know and and so you have to be very
careful that you're not apologizing for
violating the law and anything like it i
just don't like i don't like anything
other than
pending resolution to the criminal
proceeding i have nothing to say and i
understand
but i think that
yes i think that the drip drip drip of
court appearance
attorney statements sheriff's statements
all of that eventually builds up to a
point where you have to say something in
return look no maybe what he didn't do
was illegal was a fit of passion the two
women on consecutive days couldn't help
themselves and robert just went over and
they had a nice talk and he paid him
back some money that he owed him for
lunch
maybe that's what happened apparently
that's what their contention will be
however i do think that you can
acknowledge that you know heading over
to the strip mall and having a tryst in
the afternoon on consecutive days isn't
exactly what people expected of you so i
understand apologizing for the optics of
it but what what i didn't love about the
statement was invoking um
myra craft his widow and i understand
that since her passing in 2011 robert
has gone through a difficult time a sea
change personality wise he's
experiencing a world that he didn't know
prior to his marriage
and in many ways it's
been life
always it's been life altering for him
but i just don't think that
a statement addressing charges for
solicitation of prostitution is the
right place to invoke the memory of your
late wife that that i had
very strong feelings that that was a
tremendous misstep
on on his part and i think you're
putting it as mildly as you possibly can
because he's opened himself up to
criticism from any and all blogs out
there anybody in the media once we we
get to the weekday
uh morning drive afternoon drive evening
drive everything people are just gonna i
just that extra addition gives you gives
you fodder if you're inclined to heap on
robert kraft and and find something to
pick at that that's the lowest hanging
fruit that i think you could possibly
yeah i mean you can
the points about respecting women and
understanding the transactional sexual
relations are have inherent levels of
power involved in them in which the
person doing the serving is not in a
position of power that's okay you can
get through that i think that there's
just as many people out there
who are in the sex trades and i've read
about it who are sex workers who say
look don't shame us we do this out of
our own volition
and
that element is very much there as well
that we haven't you know delved into but
this in this arena it's different go
ahead right but i mean he isn't
necessarily apologizing for soliciting
prostitution because he hasn't admitted
to that correct and they have to prove
all of that that's why it's better to
justify and that's why he's asking us to
suspend all disbelief i think it would
have been better that better than the
statement that was issued would have
been saying nothing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports